welcome to tumblr headquarters home of
one of New York City's hottest tech
companies located in Manhattan's
Flatiron neighborhood tumblers office
proves it's not just a hip destination
in the digital world its office has
colorful art everything on the walls
including the bacon and the grilled
cheese are from artists or on tumblr
it has ping-pong the ping-pong tables
here is just what people can relax
it has phone booths Safari I call my
husband and say don't forget to pick up
the milk yeah sure
it even has standing desks it's
supposedly healthier but I'm too lazy to
try it
Tumblr's growth has exploded since yahoo
bought the social blogging site for 1.1
billion dollars last year
Tumblr's user base is up time spent on
the site is climbing and get this tumblr
is hiring five new people every week as
its headcount swells so is its square
footage from five thousand four years
ago to 50 thousand today I mean there
would be like seven of us on a couch
that seats four and there'd be people on
the floor and sitting on the radiators
sitting on the windowsills cramped up
and then finally we just kind of burst
out David Karp is a high school dropout
who founded tumblr seven years ago when
he was 20 years old now he's a major
player in the New York tech scene has
tumblr matures though he worries over
losing its startup nature the idea that
there are whole week's at tumblr now
where I might not cross paths with
somebody working on some particular
project is a it's a scary notion so it's
something we work really really hard to
make sure that you don't lose the sense
of family mate in New York pride is on
display throughout the office meanwhile
its owner is 2,500 miles away did a deal
with Yahoo when you think about tech the
power players are in Northern California
why not make the move brought folks on
on the west coast that question always
came up like hey there are all these
engineers out here how much of your team
do you think would be willing to move
out to the valley being born and raised
here getting as far as we have here
I just like to not imagine doing this in
any other part of the world let alone
California